Chúng ta đang tìm đại người bộ tháng 3 năm 2018, tại đạo Chương Sa, lưu đàn 1 bộ sấu,
vùng bốn hại quân tổ chức dân hương các địa điểm bình hóa.
Tâm mình và rất liều bong chuyên trước ngày dưới ra bộ cử đẹn biểu của hội khoảng
bài sấu và đại biểu hộ đồng nhân dân các cấp nhìn kiện 2020, 2018,
rồi lễ dân hương có đồng gí phản thân liên, chủ tịch i bán nhân dân đặc quốc trường Sa, chủ tịch
hội đồng bộ cử đặc quốc trường Sa, cùng cán vụ, chiến sĩ, nhân dân và cán vật
được lượng trên đạo Chương Sa.
Tại nhà tưởng nghiệm chủ tịch hồ xin mình, cán vụ, chia sĩ và nhân dân trên đạo đã thình kính tưởng liệm
bây giờ đồng biết hơn của hạn và kính trọng sâu sắp với mắt,
lãnh tụ vi đại của đảng và nhân dân ta.
Cuân dân trên đạo hư vấn hửa xin hoàn thành xuất sắp mọi nhìn vụ đạo,
tổ quốc và nhân dân tí tưởng Sa.
Cứ tâm xe dự đạo chương Sa mạnh về phòng tụ, tốt về lối sống,
đẹp về kển quan mùi chương, mẫu mẫu về đơn kết quân dân.
Tại đại tưởng nghiệm các anh hùng li xí,
mình hình phúc khuến nhân dân.
Cuân dân trên đạo nguyện một lòng chúng thình với đạo,
với tổ quốc và nhân dân tí tục kể tục sự nghiệm cách mạng về văn của các kể hệ đi trước,
quyết tâm bảo vệ vấn chắc chục quyền về đạo của tổ quốc,
có phần cùng cả nước mức bảo kỳng miếng mối, kiến miếng vinh vân mình,
phát triển tính vụ của xin tập.
Chứ quân ai, đạo tổ chức xa liệu bóng chuyển trong bương bốc cụ đại biểu của hội và đại biểu của đồng nhân dân.
Tức tục tinh trên vận động các tổ cà đá khai thác hay sản quan khu vực và hùng giấn hư dân lên đăng ký bầu cử.
Tinh đến thời điểm hiện tại khu vực bầu phía số 4 đá hùng giấn và tiếp nhận gun nha mình hư dân đăng ký tham gia bầu cử.